there's a giant peanut shaped object
orbiting the Sun and its name is
Halley's Comet like all comets it's a
cosmic mashup of frozen ice gases and
dust stretching a vast 15 kilometres by
8 kilometers this space snowball streaks
by earth every 76 years it hasn't caused
us any trouble yet but that would change
if it's elliptical return crosses paths
with our home causing a devastating
collision visible in broad daylight how
would it affect space exploration
how much damage would it do to the moon
and how would it affect us on earth this
is what if and here's what would happen
if Halley's Comet crashed into the moon
it's the Year 2060 1 and crowds are
gathering to watch the impending
fireworks we would have known about the
impact for a while because of the
predictability of the comet's orbit and
although a scary event it would be a
sight to behold
the explosion would be similar to the
2013 collision of an asteroid into the
moon which created an 8-second light
show and left a 40 metre wide crater
except Halley's Comet is 550 billion
times heavier than the 2013 asteroid so
instead of merely leaving a crater
Halley's Comet would rip the moon's
surface apart from Earth this would look
equal parts beautiful and terrifying but
on the moon it would just be pure terror
magma from the core of the Moon would
spill out shooting large plumes of dust
and material into space particles and
smaller debris would be harmless and
float around the moon but heftier chunks
would gain enough speed to escape the
gravity of the moon and enter space once
in space they would travel toward Earth
pulled by our planet's gravity
[Music]
hopefully we would have enough time to
prepare because at this point people
would need to shelter in underground
bunkers as fire rings down from above
the last time a large rock exploded in
our atmosphere was in 2013
Chelyabinsk was a 19 meter wide
meteorite and it's explosion was equal
to half a million tons of TNT if any
fallout from the moon the sooner and
size to Chelyabinsk whole cities could
be destroyed eventually we get the
all-clear to leave our bunkers some
places would only be moderately damaged
while others would be completely
demolished rebuilding would begin but
the effects of Howie's comment crashing
into our moon would be far from over our
dreams of continuing space exploration
would be dashed
we would need the moon as a pit stop to
restock and refuel for exploring space
but because of severe damage from the
comet collision landing there would be
difficult if not impossible so any
thoughts of mining the moon for the
essential raw materials to advanced
space technology wouldn't fly at the
very least NASA and other space agencies
would become better funded the world
would rely on them to keep constant
track of the dangerous moon chunks
still left in our orbit and if you're
speculating that all the dust and debris
would give earth a beautiful ring like
Saturn's Oh better luck next time or
maybe not because for a ring to form
around the earth we'd need an even
mightier collision
that's a story for another what if
[Applause]
[Music]